[Musik]
gemeinsames wahlprogramm knapp 100 tage
vor der bundestagswahl versprechen cdu
und csu ein jahrzehnt der modernisierung
neue strafmaßnahmen die eben verschärft
die wirtschaftssanktionen gegen belarus
und erhöht den druck auf machthaber
lukaschenko und ort der erinnerung nach
langem streit wird in berlin das
dokumentationszentrum über flucht
vertreibung und versöhnung eröffnet
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag an meiner seite ist für
den sport norbert leber einen schönen
gruß von mir vorbei die zeiten als
markus söder und armin laschet heftig um
die kandidatur fürs kanzleramt
konkurrierten als sie heute das
gemeinsame wahlprogramm von csu und cdu
vorstellten betonten beide parteichefs
ihre einigkeit wir werden es rocken sagt
markus söder der zentrale grundsatz des
programms entlasten statt b lasten auf
den 139 seiten steht unter anderem es
soll keine steuererhöhungen geben
kleinere und mittlere einkommen sollen
entlastet werden
die schuldenbremse bleibt und
klimaneutralität bis 2045 aber kein
tempolimit und kein diesel fahrverbot
wie hirscher hat details es treten auf
die parteivorsitzenden armin laschet und
markus söder
sie haben zwei botschaften an das
publikum man versteht sich und das
gemeinsame wahlprogramm ist fertig sie
sehen ein programm mit vielen guten
ideen aus lust aufs gestalten mit freude
daran ellenbogen wurden nur zur
begrüßung ausgefahren bis auf die mütter
rente die csu wollte die cdu abwehrte
war man sich schnell einig doch wie das
alles finanzieren
die union setzt auf wirtschaftswachstum
und legt sich auf zahlen trotz einer
nachfrage nicht fest überall programm
beschreibt doch die richtung wo es
hingehen soll und zur finanzierbarkeit
sie sagen es gibt den vorwurf den gibt's
von politischen wettbewerber den vorwurf
aber wie die 500 milliarden der grünen
finanziert werden habe ich auch noch
irgendwo gelesen
also man kann dich selbst luft
luftballons in die luft steigen lassen
und den anderen das dann vorwerfen
das ziel der schwarzen null bleibt also
unser klares ziel ist sobald es geht
wieder auf diesen pfad der finanziellen
solidität zurückzukehren um auch
souverän und zur herausforderung zu
meistern nicht abhängig zu sein von den
finanzmärkten der welt aber wir wollen
dazu nach der wahl auch eine
kassensturz machen um zu sehen was wir
versprochen deckt sich das überhaupt mit
dem was vorhanden ist
und dann ist da noch der
kanzlerkandidaten kam vom april den
söder ganz von allein aufwirft es ist
eine ähnlich gute zusammenarbeit die
waren schon vorher da und diese zehn
tage haben es nicht kaputt gemacht weißt
du das auch bestätigen kann sich also
gut die neue einigkeit verkündet und
unterzeichnet das programm sei viel zu
vage und die finanzierbarkeit bleibe
offen sagt die politische konkurrenz
theo koll in berlin was sagen sie das
waren genauso wahlen gewinnen kann
jedenfalls hat es bisher an der wahl
ohne oft nicht geschadet waage zu
bleiben und den wählern nicht zu sagen
was wo wie teuer werden soll es kann man
zynisch nennen oder auch strategisch der
sturm den die grünen ja alleine schon
durch die ankündigung ihrer 16 cent
benzinpreiserhöhung geerntet haben der
dürfte die union strategen in dieser
bewussten unschärfe und in der ja 139
seiten langen scheinbaren schmerz
losigkeit bestärkt haben besonders
augenfällig finde ich wird es bei den
steuern da soll es der aufschwung
richten trotz der korona bedingten die
angespannten öffentlichen kassen
verspricht die union steuersenkungen in
jedem fall aber keine steuererhöhungen
markus söder hat sich heute eine
hintertür offengelassen man brauche erst
einmal ein kassensturz denn er habe
zweifel an den zahlen des
finanzministers markus söder bei märkte
heute auch man könne auch grüne politik
machen ohne die grünen wie grün ist das
wahlprogramm der union also das ziel
leuchtet jedenfalls grün der weg dahin
liegt noch er im halbdunkeln bis 2045
soll die treibhausgas neutralität
erreicht werden aber das steht natürlich
auch schon im klimaschutzgesetz
um dieses ziel zu erreichen setzt die
union insbesondere auf neue technologien
und erfindungen sie will den
emissionshandel ausbauen und finanzielle
mehrbelastungen dann in den bereichen
wohnen und verkehr gezielt ausgleichen
die botschaft soll ja sein entlasten
statt belasten konkrete zahlen oder
berechenbares könnten da aber auch
stören die einschätzung von theo koll
vielen dank nach berlin
er soll ein starkes zeichen in richtung
minsk seien die eu-außenminister haben
neue sanktionen gegen belarus
beschlossen
erstmals treffen diese auch wichtige
wirtschaftszweige mit dem ziel wichtige
einnahmequellen von präsident
lukaschenko auszutrocknen
damit reagiert die eu auf die andauernde
unterdrückung von zivilgesellschaft und
opposition in belarus aus luxemburg eine
klinik svitlana die hall of ska ist
extra nach luxemburg gereist schon
länger hatte die belarussische
oppositionsführerin
die europäischen außenminister zu
härteren strafmaßnahmen gedrängt diesmal
mit erfolg
nach der erzwungenen landung einer
europäischen passagiermaschine in minsk
und der verhaftung des regimekritischen
bloggers roman botta savage erhöhen die
27 außenminister nun den druck auf das
lukaschenko regime und sind erstmals
bereit auch wirtschaftssanktionen zu
beschließen
wir wollen auf die art und weise ein
teil dazu beitragen dass dieses regime
finanziell ausgetrocknet wird und das
ist auch noch nicht das ende der
fahnenstange auf der sanktionsliste
stehen staatliche kali und düngemittel
werke die belarussische ölindustrie und
der finanzsektor
bis zum schluss war die liste je nach
geschäftsinteressen einzelner eu-länder
umstritten
die sanktionen seien auch schmerzhaft
für die europäische wirtschaft dass sie
trotzdem kommen ein zeichen der
entschlossenheit so die außenminister es
wird lange tier an oskar ist überzeugt
dass die strafmaßnahmen würden werden
sagt sie das nur für die sanktionen
betreffen nur vier prozent des
belarussischen exports das ist nicht
viel aber sie treffen ziel genau jene
firmen die lukaschenkos geldbeutel
füllen
die aktion ist mit großbritannien kanada
und den usa abgestimmt was die eu heute
feiert bleibt ein kleiner sieg statt
symbolischer sanktionen gibt es jetzt
welche die lukaschenko zumindest ein
bisschen ärgern aber solange putin den
belarussischen diktator mit milliarden
stützt bleibt der einfluss europas
begrenzt
jetzt zum thema corona gleich zu beginn
der pandemie wurden die schulen monate
lang geschlossen die uni frankfurt hat
in einer
weltweiten studie untersucht was dieser
distanz unterricht gebracht hat das
ergebnis ist ernüchternd
demnach habe der distanz unterricht die
gleichen effekte wie sommerferien gehabt
also gar keine besonders betroffen seien
schüler aus sozial schwachen familien
mittlerweile habe sich der online
unterricht aber vielerorts verbessert
die pandemie hat nicht nur bei der
bildung von kindern und jugendlichen
spuren hinterlassen sondern auch auf
ihrer seele depressionen suizidgedanken
essstörungen diese corona generation
leidet zunehmend unter psychischen
erkrankungen zum zdf thementag heute
kinder in der pandemie zeigt sandra
susanka was das bedeutet in der schule
einer psychiatrischen tagesklinik lernen
sie mit ihrer schulangst umzugehen
eine von ihnen ist marie 17 jahre alt
fuhr ohne eine gute schülerin als sie
plötzlich allein lernen soll wird sie
schwer depressiv verletzt sich selbst
meine noten haben sich extrem
verschlechtert und so ging dann halt
auch die stimmung runter ich habe mich
extrem zurückgezogen also ich bin
möglich tage lang als fast nicht mehr
aus dem zimmer gekommen
ich lag eigentlich nur noch im bett und
habe extremst viel geweint
seit corona kommen 40 prozent mehr
kinder und jugendliche in die
offenburger klinik erzählt oberärztin am
liefern dietfurt schulamt ist ein großes
thema
die ursache dafür ist häufig sind ängste
vor allem soziale ängste die die kinder
oder jugendlichen in der zeit des lok
downs ausgeprägt haben und die sich auch
sehr verstärkt haben so dass die jetzt
einfach es nicht mehr schaffen im moment
in die schule zu gehen sowie die 14
jährige julia im online unterricht traut
sie sich nicht vor den anderen zu
sprechen wird depressiv nimmt gar nicht
mehr am unterricht teil und ich kam
einfach mit dem stoff auch nicht
wirklich weiter ich bin ein komplett
hängen geblieben egal so wie viele pläne
ich mir versucht hat zu machen das zu
regeln so einfach nicht geklappt
mittlerweile macht julia eine therapie
emily ist 17 jahre alt ist magersüchtig
geworden weil ihr ohne schule die
gewohnte struktur des tages verloren
gegangen
am ende habe ich komplett das essen
verweigert
also richtung silvester wurde es dann
total schlimm und dann ging es auch
total schnell innerhalb von zwei wochen
habe ich so viel abgenommen dass man
wirklich gesagt hat ich muss jetzt
sofort stationär aufgenommen werden
julia kämpft noch gegen ihre ängste ihr
ziel wieder normal zur schule zu gehen
glücklich sein wie vor corinna jahrelang
hatte sich das projekt verzögert das war
heftig umstritten heute nun wurde es in
berlin eröffnet das
dokumentationszentrum der stiftung
flucht vertreibung versöhnung sein thema
hochaktuell weltweit sind menschen auf
der flucht zu jahresbeginn mehr als 80
millionen
im mittelpunkt steht aber die zeit nach
krieg und naziherrschaft und 14
millionen deutsche flohen oder wurden
vertrieben
die meisten aus schlesien aus ostpreußen
und pommern netz schneider berichtet
erich jung war 14 jahre alt als er und
seine familie 1946 vertrieben wurden
ihre heimat war der ort karte zum
nördlichen sudetenland damals teil der
tschechoslowakei hat mich an ein
leiterwagen wo und in sachen drauf waren
um auf meine großeltern denn immer
laufen konnten und hat auch gold mit
einem güterzug wurde die familie nach
sachsen gebracht in ein auffanglager in
dem jeder fünfte an hunger oder
krankheiten starb das museum zeigt
dieses schwierige kapitel deutscher
geschichte
die bundeskanzlerin ist per video
zugeschaltet es ist von entscheidender
bedeutung dass die vertreibungs
geschichte der deutschen in ihrem
historischen kontext von ursache und
folgen eingebettet und nicht isoliert
dargestellt wird wer auf solchen
leiterwagen fliehen musste hatte fast
noch glück viele durften nur das
mitnehmen was sie tragen konnten
alle exponate sind von zeitzeugen
gespendet die ausstellung zeigt immer
ursache und wirkung ohne den von
deutschland ausgelösten zweiten
weltkrieg hätte es die vertreibungen
nicht gegeben
das zentrum widmet sich auch der
versöhnung
wir möchten einen beitrag dazu leisten
dass die geschichten die erzählt werden
die zusammenhänge die aufgemacht werden
dass sie zum verständnis eines großen
kapitels der zeitgeschichte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts beitragen indem
die deutschen eine doppelrolle gespielt
haben sowohl als vertreiber als auch als
vertriebene eine große rolle im neuen
zentrum spielen auch flucht und
vertreibung der gegenwart etwa aus
syrien oder myanmar der region fand in
der früheren ddr seine neue heimat als
designer hat er zum beispiel die
weltzeituhr auf dem berliner
alexanderplatz entworfen
die deutsche gesellschaft und die
jüdische gemeinschaft in deutschland
haben einen langen weg zurückgelegt um
diesen historischen moment zu erreichen
sagt zsolt balla er ist seit heute der
erste jüdische militärseelsorger der
bundeswehr in der leipziger synagoge
wurde sachsens landesrabbiner feierlich
in das amt eingeführt
er sehe die besondere verantwortung und
wolle für alle in der bundeswehr dasein
soballa bis zu zehn weitere rabbiner
sollen freundin überraschung in
frankreich aus den regionalwahlen geht
vor allem das konservative lager
gestärkt hervor es landet bei knapp 30
prozent der stimmen abgeschlagen
dahinter die rechtspopulisten unter
marine le pen mit weniger als 20 prozent
die partei von präsident makro holte nur
gut 11 prozent
die wahlbeteiligung war mit rund 30
prozent sehr niedrig nach schweden dort
hat das parlament ministerpräsident wen
das vertrauen entzogen damit ist seine
mitte links regierung praktisch
abgewählt anlass war der streit über das
mietrecht der sozialdemokrat hat nun
zwei möglichkeiten rücktritt oder
neuwahlen
die entscheidungen muss innerhalb einer
woche fallen nach ostafrika jetzt groß
war die hoffnung als in äthiopien abu
ahmed premierminister wurde und dann
auch noch den friedensnobelpreis bekam
die parlamentswahl heute gilt auch als
abstimmung über den 44-jährigen 2018 war
abdi ahmed als reformer angetreten hat
der demokratisierung und einheit
versprochen doch in der region tigray
tobt ein blutiger konflikt deswegen
konnten die menschen dort nicht
abstimmen
tim kröger schon am morgen lange
schlangen vor den wahllokalen in der
hauptstadt addis abeba äthiopien wählt
allerdings zu einer zeit da das land von
konflikten hunger und vertreibung
geprägt ist ich möchte dass keiner in
diesem land stirbt und das jeder als
bürger respektiert wird
das tötet ihn überall und die ethnische
spaltung müssen aufhören
im wahlkampf noch gab sich
regierungschef ahmed als das was er
tatsächlich mal war als hoffnungsträger
anfangs hatte er das land geöffnet mit
aa2 und ihre träger frieden geschlossen
und dafür den friedensnobelpreis
bekommen
längst aber ist die realität eine andere
der provinz tigray herrscht krieg eine
massive hungersnot droht in anderen
teilen des landes brechen immer wie der
ethnische konflikt auf politische gegner
machen premier ahmed für diese
entwicklung verantwortlich
wenn ich gerd bauer als an die macht kam
gab es hoffnung bei den menschen dass er
einen nationalen konsens unter den
politischen eliten herstellt damit der
wandel im land sank der wird aber das
hat er nicht getan wird die natur viele
beobachter gehen davon aus dass die
partei von regierungschef abu ahmed
diese wahl gewinnen allerdings in
einigen regionen kann sie derzeit gar
nicht stattfinden und mehrere
oppositionsparteien nehmen nicht teil
es ist die erste wahl der sich
premierminister ahmed stellen musste bei
einem wahlsieg muss er zeigen ob er doch
noch ein demokratischer reformer ist
oder einen zunehmend autoritären kurs
verfolgt
der friedenspreis des deutschen
buchhandels geht in diesem jahr an eine
autorin und filmemacherin aus simbabwe
zieht sie dann gar m
sie seien nicht nur eine der wichtigsten
künstlerinnen ihres landes sondern auch
eine weithin hörbare stimme afrikas in
der gegenwartsliteratur so die jury in
simbabwe engagiert sich die 62-jährige
auch im kampf gegen korruption
verliehen wird der preis am 24 oktober
in der frankfurter paulskirche und jetzt
noch was in eigener sache
das fernsehverhalten hat sich verändert
viele wollen ihre lieblingssendungen
nicht mehr nur live und linear im
fernsehen sehen sondern eben auch online
wann immer sie wollen zugriff darauf
haben
diesem wunsch kommen ard und zdf jetzt
noch weiter entgegen mit einem
gemeinsamen streaming netzwerk bobic r
und susanne gelhard haben details mit
einem klick alle inhalte der mediatheken
von zdf und ard abrufen das bietet
künftig das neue streaming netzwerk
beider sender 250.000 filme dokus serien
satire ein gemeinsamer streaming kosmos
von ard und zdf
die idee vom neuen streaming netzwerk
von zdf und ard ist deswegen bestechen
gut weil es für die nutzerinnen und
nutzer so einfach ist sie bleiben
weiterhin auf der zdf mediathek suche
nach inhalten fernsehfilm dokumentation
und nach und nach kommen die inhalte
dazu das gleiche natürlich auf der
mediathek und am ende steht dann für die
nutzerinnen nutzer best-of
öffentlich-rechtliches qualität
wer die zdf mediathek nutzt kann dann
dort auch den tatort suchen und landet
direkt an der richtigen stelle der ard
mediathek
wer umgekehrt die heute show bei der ard
ab ruft gelangt sofort zur zdf mediathek
und wer ein zdf oder ard konto hat
bekommt künftig passende inhalte aus
beiden mediatheken angeboten
das streaming netzwerk wurde heute vom
ard-vorsitzenden buhrow zdf-intendant
blut und swr-intendant gniffke
vorgestellt
es gibt im moment in deutschland
natürlich eine riesen nachfrage nach
streaming angeboten und da stellen wir
fest dass die anbieter aus übersee im
moment die nase vorne haben aber wir
finden es zeit dass auch in deutschland
ist ein anbieter gibt der werte
getrieben ist er nicht nur darauf guckt
möglichst geld damit zu verdienen
das streaming netzwerk von zdf und ard
soll nun in den kommenden monaten
ausgebaut werden
die brütende hitze der letzten tage hat
in einigen teilen deutschlands ein jähes
ende gefunden mit heftigen gewittern
besonders betroffen der süden über
neu-ulm in bayern etwa zog ein sturm mit
starkregen und hagel hinweg bäume
stürzten auf parkende autos und
versperrten straßen am stuttgarter
flughafen lief ein tunnel voll ebenso
viele keller in der region und damit
sind wir bei der fußball-em norbert und
dem gespannten blick auf die
nationalmannschaft ja und die ist nach
dem 4 2 sieg gegen portugal natürlich in
bester laune
vor dem letzten vorrundenspiel
übermorgen gegen ungarn betrüblich
allerdings drei schlüsselspieler sind
angeschlagen darunter die beiden team
rückkehrer mats hummels und thomas
müller
die trainings reihen haben sich etwas
gelichtet heute in herzogenaurach ohne
müller hummels und gündogan begann der
bundestrainer mit der vorbereitung auf
das letzte gruppenspiel
das größte fragezeichen steht momentan
hinter dem einsatz von thomas müller der
sich hinter schlussminuten gegen
portugal am knie verletzte thomas ist
natürlich eine absolute bereicherung für
uns hier das merkt man sowohl auf als
auch neben dem platz
dementsprechend klar wäre es für uns
alle sehr sehr schade wenn er nicht
dabei sein könnte
der einsatz der angeschlagenen
ausgewechselten mats hummels und ilkay
gündogan ist ebenfalls noch unsicher
aber momentan wahrscheinlicher als der
von müller torschütze robin goossens
konnte voll mit trainieren und steht
bereit wird die mannschaft am mittwoch
ausläuft um die zuschauer aufs neue zu
begeistern
tut einfach gut wieder 82 millionen
bundestrainer zu haben und nicht 82
millionen virologen man merkt einfach
dass landes wieder euphorisiert und
hat spaß am fußball so wie es sein soll
das trifft auch auf die mannschaft zu
mit spaß an der sache wollen sie
übermorgen in münchen den gruppensieg
anpeilen und manuel neuer wird auch
gegen ungarn wieder mit einer
kapitänsbinde in regenbogenfarben
auflaufen als zeichen für vielfalt und
gegen homophobie ja und inzwischen hat
die stadt münchen offiziell bei der uefa
beantragt die arena am mittwoch auch in
den regenbogenfarben illuminieren zu
dürfen japans olympia organisatoren
wollen bis zu 10.000 zuschauer bei den
wettkämpfen den tokio zu lassen
allerdings darf nur die hälfte der
plätze in den arenen besetzt werden
ausländischen besuchern bleibt die
einreise zu den sommerspielen verwehrt
und sollte sich die krone lage in tokio
wieder verschlechtern müssen die stadien
leer bleiben mit 32 tagen geht es auf
jeden fall los in tokio mit oder ohne
publikum
vielen dank auch morgen wird es
ungemütlich mit unwetter wann und wo
erfahren sie gleich von westen terry im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn stellt
sich unions kanzlerkandidat armin
laschet den fragen von bettina schausten
wir danken für ihr interesse und freuen
uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei sind
einen schönen abend noch auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die feucht-warme
luft ist eingeklemmt mittlerweile
zwischen einem umfangreichen hoch im
osten und weit draußen auf dem atlantik
so drehen sich die tiefste nun um sich
herum und sorgen hier für teils heftige
gewitter in den nächsten stunden und vor
allem in der ersten nachthälfte schauen
wir uns das an im süden vor allem
heftige gewitter mit den üblichen
verdächtigen also hagel sturmböen und
platzregen sehr viele regen in kurzer
zeit und im norden
da merkt man kaum etwas davon die
temperaturen sinken dabei eher auf 18
grad im osten deutschlands hier ist es
am mildesten und am kühlsten richtung
emsland und schleswig holstein mit zehn
grad
morgen am vormittag gibt es im südwesten
erste gewitter ansonsten ziehen die
gewitter im osten allmählich ab
dazwischen lockert es auf die sonne
kommt hervor und am nachmittag ändert
sich das bild da wird es im süden zur
sache gehen mit weiteren heftigen
gewittern hagel sturm und großen
regenmengen im norden wieder kaum etwas
zu spüren davon bei höchsten
temperaturen von 29 grad im südosten und
17 grad an der nordsee
die nächsten tage sind nicht mehr ganz
so warm aber die unwetterartigen
gewittern bleiben und zu erhalten ein
schöner abend